Does being around groups of people make
you energetic or does it exhausts you,
and if,
if you're the sort of person that will
go to a party and interact with 20
people,
Indian and you have to go home and be by
yourself for like two weeks,
then you're introverted.
Introverts are exhausted by social
interactions.
Extroverts are the opposite.
They all,
they're,
they're energized by social interactions
and you know,
you might be in the middle so that you
can take it or leave it with regards to
social interactions,
but you're happy to go to them and
you're happy to spend time by yourself.
But a real extrovert.
There'll be some of you in here.
How many of you can't stand spending
time alone?
Okay,
so there's only two that will admit it.
Extroverts are more likely to admit that
sort of thing too,
by the way.
But then how many of you you like to
spend time alone or would rather be
alone?
Okay,
so there is a preponderance of
introverts in this class is by the,
by,
by all appearances.
But that's a really,
that's a pretty canonical question for,
for extroversion versus introversion.
It's a very stable trait by the way.
It manifests itself early in life and
it's stable across the age span,
not completely.
Introverts can learn to be extroverted,
to extroverts,
can learn to spend time on their own.
I think that actually your capacity to
expand your ability past the initial
constraints of your biological
temperament is something like the
development of character or wisdom you
know.
So if you're an introvert by nature and
you learn how to be extroverted,
then that expands your domain of
competence.
And if you're extroverted,
you learned to be introverted.
The same thing,
but it's almost like imagine a
distribution of extroversion,
introversion here,
extroversion here,
a normal distribution you're set when
you're young at somewhere along that
distribution with some range around it.
And I think what you do as you mature,
if you develop your skills as you expand
that range,
but you're set,
the place at which you're set doesn't
move that much.
So okay,
so there's.
So you can think about them as
subpersonalities.
You can think about them as frames of
reference.
So frame of reference would be something
like,
well,
since you're extroverted,
you value being with people and so
you're gonna.
Look at the world.
For example,
if you're extroverted,
you come into a room like this,
you think,
oh look,
it's a whole field of opportunity for
social interactions.
And if you're introverted you think,
well maybe I'll go sit up in the corner
and everybody leaves me the hell alone.